Speaker 1: Donald Trump held his final,
unhinged, extreme lunatic rally in front of
a crowd of sycophants last night in Vandalia,
Ohio. And there were rumors that he was going
to announce his 2024 candidacy. Trump did make
an announcement of a further announcement and
a lot of people highly titillated by this.
Take a look at Trump's big announcement.
Speaker 2: I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday,
November 15, at Mar a Lago in Palm Beach, Florida.
Speaker 1: Florida. Okay.
So. By all reasonable assessments. Next Tuesday,
Trump will be announcing that he is running for
the Republican presidential nomination in 2024.
This was a particularly disgusting rally. The
energy was extra dangerous. One of the targets of
Trump in the last few days has been Nancy Pelosi.
And it is quite horrifying. We will get to that
momentarily. Donald Trump insisting, you know,
maybe he should be given back the nuclear codes.
Speaker 2: In his socks. Nothing happened to him
except a great verdict. He's got a great verdict.
We go by that verdict, the Saxe verdict. But no,
he had it in his socks. You know that. Right.
And others took many, many documents. They
take him out of the White House. They took the
argument, I'm the only one that can take anything.
But maybe our country would be better off if
I actually had the nuclear codes. JD
Because our enemies would be afraid,
unlike the way they are now. If I think about.
Speaker 1: What he's saying, he's saying
I am so unstable that I actually might just on a
whim nuke people that me having the codes would
be a good deterrent.
Speaker 2: Nuclear
codes. Bill Clinton. Don't forget,
he lost the nuclear codes twice.
How do you explain that to the military who
have lost the military codes? Why? He lost
the military codes twice. I didn't. They're
coming after me because I'm fighting for you.
Speaker 1: That's completely unhinged. I mean,
this this is a man at this point so disconnected
from reality and sanity that it is hard to
believe. Trump Then going after Nancy Pelosi, of
course, Nancy Pelosi's husband recently attacked
by a right wing nut in their home. He had to have
skull surgery. And here's Trump talking about her.
Speaker 2: He Pelosi said,
please don't call them animals. They're
human beings. I said, No, they're animals
because I think she's an animal too.
You want to know the terms? What?
They'll say, Oh, what a horrible thing he
said about that. She impeached me twice
for nothing. Nothing. They'll say, Oh, these
people are fakers back there. They'll say,
What a horrible thing. He called Nancy Pelosi
an animal. Let me tell you what she does to this
country and what she did to it and the turmoil.
And it was all. I used the word yesterday. I
shouldn't. My great first lady got very upset. I
said, I will never use the word bullshit again.
But what she did to us in this country, and
yet we got more done as an administration
and a president than just about any
president in the history of our country
in four years.
Speaker 1:
So continued attacks on Nancy Pelosi, extremely
poor taste, classless. As I've said before,
money cannot buy you class. Now, interestingly,
former Ted Cruz staffer Amanda Carpenter tweeted
last night, quote, I haven't seen a Trump speech
in a while, but the way he spoke last night so
favorably of executing drug dealers after a
short two hour or less trial and then sending the
bullet they were shot with to their families was
jarring. Well, what Amanda Carpenter doesn't know
is that this has actually been part of Trump's
routine at every rally for the last several
months. And Kevin McCarthy was even asked about
this on CNN and he's like, No, no, no. We kind
of should be changing the law to execute drug
dealers. This is a sick and disgusting group
of people. Here's the clip that Amanda Carpenter
is referring to. And again, if you haven't been
paying attention to these rallies, you probably
would be horrified by this. But Trump does this
at every rally and the crowd cheers. The
world is horrified. But the crowd cheers.
Speaker 2: I am calling for the death penalty
for drug dealers and human traffickers, which
will. On this passage reduce drug distribution and
reduce crime in our country by a minimum of 75% on
the first day that this policy is instituted. And
maybe I could ask J.D. to lead it. You will never
lose an election again if you did. And I don't
like to bring this up. It's a tough subject.
Nobody I don't know if the country is ready for
it. I can tell you with President Xi in China,
I see him say, president, you have 1.5 billion
people. Do you have a drug problem? No,
no. Listen to this. Listen to this. How
do you do that? I really sort of knew,
but I didn't want to. How do you do that? And then
he probably thought I was somewhat naive. He goes,
We have a quick trial. I said, It was a quick
try. I think I knew what that was, too. That
means they catch a drug dealer. They give them a
quick trial, not a trial that takes 12 years and
12 years of appeals 25 years later, and everyone's
dead by the time they get to the end of that. Now,
this is a trial that takes approximately 2 hours.
Speaker 1: This is extraordinarily authoritative,
authoritarian. This this is you know,
Russia has a 99% conviction rate, red flag,
authoritarian nightmare.
Speaker 2: And if they're
guilty, they are executed. And the end, the
bullet and you know the bullet. I don't know
if anybody wants to know this. It gets a little
bit too graphic. But the bullet is said to their
families that right. You know, that it's actually
sent to their families. It's pretty tough stuff.
There's no games, so they have no drug problem
whatsoever. He actually thought it was a foolish
question. I said, do you have a drug problem?
Absolutely not. What are you talking about?
Speaker 1: Of course. Now let's insert
a little bit of sanity into what is a
completely insane situation. During this
rant, Trump always claims every drug dealer
kills 500 Americans. Each drug dealer is
responsible directly for killing 500 Americans.
That's just made up. I mean, just. Just Google it.
Look for the information. Check out anything you
want to check. There is no ever. He's grappled on
to that fact. That is not a fact. That claim. And
it is based in nothing. That's number one now.
Number two, even for Trumps, all of Toughed,
all of Trump's tough talk about execute drug
dealers, do a two hour trial, send the bullet
to their families, even despite all of that. Trump
pardoned many drug dealers when he was in office.
So even his own supposed disdain and desperation
for harsher treatment of drug dealers, Trump
pardoned many drug dealers when he was in office.
So just another instance of hypocrisy for sure.
Last thing here, and we're not doing a ton of
these clips today. We've got a lot of old things.
Trump has started to refer to Trump rallies as
religious experiences and in fact referred to
the moment when it started pouring at his Miami
rally on Sunday as such a religious experience.
Speaker 2: But, you know, the people it was
actually people have said today it was like
a religious experience, the people, the music
comes on and then boom, we just get. It was like,
unbelievable. I've never seen anything like
it. Right. You know, the teleprompter is one
of them just crashed and broke.
Speaker 1: Now, remember,
for years, he criticized Barack Obama
for using a teleprompter. And now Trump
is talking about forget about the fact that
he uses a teleprompter at every speech. He's
talking about the fact that without it, it was
really difficult to continue giving a speech.
Speaker 2: The other word was useless because
you have it right in your car where you get a
really heavy rainstorm and try and see through
without the windshield wipers, which, by the way,
they planned. It's called planned obsolescence.
They can make a windshield wiper that would last
100 years, but they make them only. So they
last exactly one year. And then you have to
buy a new one, which means they're smart. Okay.
Speaker 1: Trump probably doesn't realize you
just take a paper towel to the windshield wiper
and then, you know, you get another year out
of it every time you do it. But anyway,
this is that's too pedestrian for Trump.
Speaker 2: Let's let him keep it. But do
you ever do that when you're driving and you
can't see? Well, that's what I had with my one
little remaining teleprompter. So we had to go
and we had a great evening. One of the greatest
rallies we've ever had. And it was caused by God
sending us the heaviest rain I've ever seen.
Speaker 1: You know what's funny about that?
And then we'll move on. Some of you might remember
when Trump was inaugurated in January of 2017, he
claimed that the rain stopped and the sun came out
and it was a sign from God about how happy God was
about Trump being president. Now. It was a lie.
It was just rainy that day. But most importantly,
the point was God expresses his pleasure by
making it sunny. And now Trump is saying God
expressed displeasure by sending rain to make it
like a religious experience that is emblematic of
right wing thinking. When it happens, it's because
things are really good. But when the opposite of
happens, it's because things are really good. The
meaning of A and the opposite of A is the same
depending on what's convenient at the time. This
guy is almost certainly announcing next Tuesday
that he's running for president. It is going to
be an insane two years. It will be worse if these
people clean house tonight. Let's hope we've all
voted. Let's hope we prevent them from doing it.